nous avec nous sur ce studio catherine
deneuve bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes en partie cette votre présence
s'explique en partie par la défense que
voudriez faire de certains producteurs
européens qui prennent des risques en
défendant des petits films notamment le
portugais paulo branco
oui j'aurais bien voulu être à
strasbourg ce soir mais je tournais
encore hier un film en belgique donc je
pouvais être à la soirée aujourd'hui on
rend hommage à paolo branco qui était un
producteur portugais qui a produit
beaucoup de films pour simon europe
beaucoup de films de langue étrangère
mais des films européens des films
parfois tourner aussi en france et c'est
quelqu'un de très de très audacieux de
créer de très cinéphile et je trouve je
suis très très contente parce qu'il est
quand même très jeunes et les
producteurs depuis très longtemps mais
il est très jeune
je suis très contente qu'on lui rend un
hommage aussi important aujourd'hui à
strasbourg à son âge mais je sais très
bien lors au delà des initiatives
courageuses de certains producteurs
comme comme ce portugais qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour défendre
le cinéma européen
qu'est ce que vous attendez puisque vous
avez avec vous catherine trautmann
précisément des pouvoirs publics par
exemple je suis pas vraiment là je crois
franchement pour parler à ce niveau là
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec l'as
dit catherine trautmann et sur les
engagements que j'ai pris je pense qu'il
ya déjà beaucoup de choses qui sont
faites en france pour soutenir le cinéma
français et c'est vrai que si le cinéma
français dans une situation quand même
encore possible c'est vrai qu'il ya
quand même des systèmes qui permettent
au film d'exister de se tourner et à des
auteurs et des réalisateurs de faire le
vide dans des conditions quand même
assez assez formidable aujourd'hui mais
c'est vrai que le problème se pose aussi
au niveau de la distribution
c'est vrai que nous on a un système qui
fait que de toute façon les quotas sont
tellement importants que beaucoup des
films français passent à la télévision
donc il ya une demande une nécessité
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya aussi un
problème au niveau de la de la diffusion
des sites de la distribution et que et
je sais par exemple que par l'eau branco
encore lui a acheté une salle de cinéma
qui est une salle mythique ceux des pour
les cinéphiles qui est l'action
république et donc il va faire de la
distribution ce sera une chose
évidemment très limité puisque c'est un
cinéma d'art et d'essai avec tout ce que
ça comporte je veux dire de deux limites
par rapport à un grand public mais je
pense que c'est au niveau de la
distribution c'est vrai qu'il faudrait
que il ya un effort de fait pour
soutenir peut-être davantage les teams
français mais je ne pense pas qu'on
puisse
évitez le raz-de-marée américain mais
c'est vrai qu'il n'ya pas de raison par
exemple que moi quand je vais aux états
unis je suis sidéré de voir quand même
qu'ils aient si peu de films étrangers
ils sont quand même eux je trouve très
protectionniste vis-à-vis de leur cinéma
en amérique très position très très très
fermé quand même donc je trouve normal
qu'on fasse un effort pour soutenir le
cinéma européen
la nemo catherine trautmann êtes sur
iphone ou de strasbourg est ce que c'est
pas une sorte de combat donquichottesque
justement vu encore une fois la
puissance des grands majors américains
et puis le poids de la langue anglaise
dans le monde c'est pas rien même et la
langue française des langues européennes
l'italien le portugais fait mais il faut
penser aussi que quand même les langue
française tout amérique du sud vous dire
par l'espagnol l'europe c'est aussi
l'espagnol est tout amérique du sud le
mexique tous ces pays sont concernés une
partie du canada donc présager c'est un
geste acceptant un combat je pense bête
montre du moulin vous non je ne pense
pas me battre contre un moulin van est
d'autant plus que ce que je constate
c'est que le public lorsqu'il a le choix
s'est aussi appréciée des signes de
création on le voit en ce moment dans le
succès d'un certain nombre de films
distribués en salles
je voudrais en même temps si vous le
permettez salué le travail que fait
catherine denave auprès de l'unesco pour
valoriser et engager l'ensemble des pays
à protéger et restaurer et diffuser le
patrimoine cinématographique je crois
que c'est extrêmement important que
l'ensemble du public est taxé à une
connaissance du film a une histoire ça
peut lui permettre aussi de former son
regard de comprendre aujourd'hui la
place que tient le film pour comprendre
notre société et la regarde et peut-être
avec un air plus humains je crois
beaucoup que le cinéma peut apporter
il est à la fois oeuvre de création il
est en même temps aussi un regard sur le
monde et si la télévision un peu
supplanté les écrans ça je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il a encore de beaux
jours devant lui merci beaucoup
catherine trautmann excusez moi
effectivement j'étais troublé par votre
présence catherine deneuve et j'ai
oublié de rappeler aux téléspectateurs
que travaille effectivement pour une
mission mais je trouve que c'est très
important de le rappeler parce que quand
on a quand on l'a fait l'anniversaire du
cinéma on a fêté les 50 ans du cinéma ça
paraît très très vieux or c'est le
7e art c'est vraiment l'art le plus
jeune qui existe et le ciné loin est
vraiment l'art le plus populaire donc
c'est vrai qu'il faut penser qu'il n'y
aura pas de d'art populaire qui restera
s'il n'y a pas de mémoire
et s'il n'y a pas de souvenirs donc si
on ne fait pas des efforts pour
préserver le patrimoine qui est très
fragile et très coûteux à conserver donc
je compte beaucoup sur la générosité des
sponsors publics et de nos sponsors
privés par des coureurs et des à la
restauration du patrimoine oui merci
beaucoup
catherine trautmann merci beaucoup
catherine deneuve